as the United States shoots down the
fourth flying object encroaching on our
airspace and as a second and third train
derail in different parts of the country
just days after the catastrophic Ohio
derailment that sent a million pounds of
poison up into the air the White House
wants to assure everyone that it has the
situations under control
one last thing before I turn it over to
the Admiral I just wanted to make sure
we addressed this from the White House I
know there have been questions and and
concerns about this but there is no
again no indication of aliens or
extraterrestrial activity with these
recent takedowns again there is no
indication of aliens or terrestrial
activity with these recent takedowns
wanted to make sure that the American
people knew that all of you knew that
and it was important for us to say that
from here because we've been hearing a
lot about it
I have never been more inclined to
believe in aliens in my life
you know that I am pretty anti-alien I
don't think aliens are real
Karine Jean-Pierre saying that aliens
aren't real
it's the strongest evidence yet
that the that the truth is out there you
know I'm pretty sure she was joking or
at least she was trying to joke she
didn't even land the joke she said there
is no evidence of aliens or terrestrial
activity not extraterrestrial
terrestrial activity terrestrial meaning
here on Earth which sadly seems to be
the case the spy planes keep popping up
the trains carrying poison keep running
off the track and the White House
doesn't seem to have any explanations or
plans to do much of anything about it my
favorite response so far to the whole
UFO spy balloon
incident has been from China and China's
response first was this isn't us then it
was oh it's actually it's a civilian
aircraft by accident then that neither
of those were tenable whatsoever it was
clear it was a Chinese spy aircraft so
now what the Chinese are saying is yeah
we're seeing a lot of UFOs too
isn't that weird all of us in this
together with all them UFOs out here
according to authorities in China this
is being reported by the state-run
newspaper the global times quote local
Maritime authorities in East China's
Shandong Province announced on Sunday
that they had spotted an unidentified
flying object in waters near the coastal
city of rizao
in the province and we're preparing to
shoot it down reminding fishermen to be
safe
seems kind of convenient I don't I don't
think they're going to find much of
anything I don't think they're going to
find
Little Green Men I don't think they're
going to find many American aircrafts
certainly not flying over mainland China
certainly not right now I think China
got caught with its pants down
and now the Biden Administration is
trying desperately to to try to stop not
just the damage to National Security
they I think to them the national
security issue is a second thought
they're trying to stop the political
Fallout which has been tremendous but
there's a much more important Story and
there's Fallout that we should be much
more concerned about that's in Ohio so I
talked about it yesterday there is a
bizarre media blackout almost at least a
media brownout of this train derailment
in Ohio that sent a million pounds of
poison of just one kind of poison into
the atmosphere and nobody seems to be
talking about it now we've found out
that there are more poisons that were on
this train according to the Norfolk
Southern Railroad and the EPA the the
train in addition to vinyl chloride
which as it leaked was poisonous enough
but then when they set it on fire for a
controlled burn created hydrochloric
acid and phosgene which is one of the
point and gases from World War One just
all through the atmosphere in addition
to that the train was carrying ethylene
glycol monobutyl ether maybe it's
unclear if if that was a if that was one
of the cars that derailed that's a
highly combustible liquid used to
manufacture paints and varnish ingestion
or skin contact from that can cause a
headache nausea vomiting or dizziness uh
if trains seem to have been carrying
isobutylene though again it's not
confirmed that there was any breach of
of that train car that's a flammable gas
that can induce dizziness drowsiness and
unconsciousness
when even moderate concentrations are
inhaled and then there was ethyl hexel
acrylate that one does appear to have
leaked out of the trains that's a
combustible liquid used to make paints
and Plastics the amount of the chemical
remaining in the car is pending
according to Norfolk Southern and that
substance has been identified as a
carcinogen in lab experiments according
to the National Library of Medicine so
this is a much much bigger story than
hey look over at the shiny object in the
sky pay no attention to the train
derailing in Ohio that could affect the
water supply for upwards of 10 percent
of the United States oh no it's fine the
animals are dropping instantly it looks
as though by every sign we can see
there's poison everywhere but don't
worry I'm sure the air is safe go back
to your home nothing to see here go pay
attention to E.T this is a really really
serious story the fact that our
corporate hack press is mostly ignoring
it tells you it's it's an even bigger
story and it's followed by some pretty
weird coincidence evidences so yesterday
in South Carolina there was another
train derailment
doesn't seem to have been any hazardous
material on that train but a train did
derail there and then also yesterday A
Train derailed in Houston and the cargo
on that train did seem to include some
hazardous materials not nearly as
hazardous as the train in Ohio but this
prompted Union Pacific to start
monitoring air quality at the site of
the crash
now
you might be looking at this and saying
are we under attack is this is this war
did World War III begin whether it's
from the Alien Invasion or from the
Chinese Invasion and it turns out
trains derail a fair bit
so I googled this I knew that there was
going to be spin from the libs so I
wanted to find an article from before
the Ohio incident because if after the
Ohio derailment you saw a news article
that said Oh No actually that's not
trains derail all the time you just
wouldn't believe it right just like how
after the covid vaccine you saw these
articles oh no myocarditis in 15 year
olds that happens all the time no
there's nothing to see here move along
Move Along oh no you can eggs are always
ten dollars a dozen what do you come on
there's nothing but if the Articles were
out before the Ohio derailment they're
much more credible
and so I found one from last June this
is from the hill I was talking about a
train derailment that occurred in in
Missouri uh turns out that there are
there are lots of train derailments
every year from 1990 the first year that
they started tracking these derailments
and injuries uh 1990 to 2021 there
apparently have been 54 539 accidents in
which a Train derailed
which means that over that 30 31 year
period of time
there were an average of
1704 derailments per year
shouldn't we fix that
I hate to beat up on mayor Pete
I actually love to beat up on mayor Pete
mayor Pete probably my least favorite
member of the Biden Administration isn't
that something he should maybe look into
it's not just his fault obviously there
have been many Transportation
secretaries before him during the period
1990 to present but
shouldn't they fix that isn't
we're sending rocket ships up into outer
space and then Landing them back on
Earth
you can get around the world very very
quickly
we're bringing back Hypersonic
commercial air travel pretty soon we've
got self-driving cars shouldn't we be
able to keep the trains on the tracks
isn't that I don't know I assume mayor
Pete is planning on taking some more
paternity extra vacation leave he's very
very busy he's got a he's got to solve
the racism of bridges in Long Island I
know he's he's really focused on those
pressing problems
maybe though our transportation policy
should involve keeping the trains on the
tracks
because While most of the derailments
don't seem to result in many injuries at
least what just happened in Ohio is a
big deal
and the fact that you're not hearing
about it very much
tells you how big a deal it is maybe
that should be a higher priority the
rest of the show continues now the
member block is on you don't want to
miss it use code Knowles kwles a
checkout for two months free on all
annual plans dailywire.com Knowles we
will see you in the member block
[Music]
foreign